so as we get into the second part and
the conclusion of Batman court of owls
what we need to do is we kind of need to
rehash the first video a bit and that we
had seen that there had been a series of
incidents a series of murders that had
that Batman had been investigating it
had really led to the idea that the
court of owls which Batman considered to
be a myth may very well be real it was
our introduction from Scott Snyder into
the realm of the court of owls in Batman
new 52 and so ultimately we found that
Bruce Wayne was investigating all these
different I guess places all these
different 13th floors and various
buildings that have been expanded on
over the years and each of these
buildings that had a 13th floor had an
apartment that was dedicated to the
court of owls had all kinds of different
paraphernalia which ultimately resulted
and some sort of explosion which
presumably had killed Bruce Wayne but
what we find here is we begin the second
part and the conclusion of the court of
owls is that we learned that of course
Bruce Wayne has survived in addition we
also see that he's joined by Dick
Grayson and what Bruce Wayne is doing
here at least as he explains it to Dick
Grayson is that he's analyzing the bones
of a long dead relative of Alan Wayne
and the reason why is because the
question was if Alan Wayne had died
under suspicious circumstances or under
weird circumstances given how Batman's
deciphered it and if he had an obsession
with owls towards the end of his life
then perhaps if the court of owls is
real he was murdered by the court of
owls and this is really Batman beginning
to give credence to the idea that the
court of owls exists this is really him
beginning to sort of give way to this
philosophy and so what happens here is
that we see the Dick Grayson is
basically appealing to Batman what he's
telling Bruce Wayne is that he's
basically been working in the candle at
both ends that everybody's worried about
him that he has been slaving away
he's been almost at an obsession with
this and the problem was that if Bruce
Wayne doesn't slow down that he may very
well get himself killed here and so what
happens is that again Bruce Wayne begins
to tell Dick Grayson why it is that he's
so obsessed with the court of owls why
it is that he believes a court of owls
may very well be real but at the same
time doesn't want to believe that it's
real and this reason is because when his
parents were killed for him as a child
he had to believe there was some kind of
a conspiracy of play that it couldn't
just be one man who was dead
on his luck and that he and his parents
happen to be in the wrong place at the
wrong time as a child he knew the legend
of the court of owls he knew the old
stories of the court of owls and so as
far as Bruce Wayne was concerned as a
child the court of Allison most likely
murdered his parents now this was a
little more I guess given to us a little
more solid when Bruce Wayne had seen
that there was an owl that had been
perched in the Attic of the home and so
for him he said that in this older I
guess older version of the story there
had been a line about heeding the signs
and so for him this was basically a sign
that had been left for his parents by
the court of owls which they did not
heed and as a result the court of owls
had murdered his parents and so what he
did is he began going on this sort of
investigative during this in fact would
be his first real role as a detective
that we would find him undertaking later
on and as he goes to this entire process
of trying to figure out what's what what
had taken place with his parents
the first thing began to do was analyze
the people that his parents associated
with the people that his parents had
dealings with and so as time progressed
and as he began to dive deeper into this
entire concept he eventually came across
what appeared to be a place called the
harbor house now the harbor house as he
describes it is a location whereby all
these different people that his father
that his parents had associates with or
that his parents had dealings with had
in some way been connected to the harbor
house at the same time the harbor house
had indications of owls on it and so for
Bruce Wayne as a child the evidence was
clear that this was some kind of a safe
haven for the court of owls in addition
he had looked at the schematics of the
blueprints for the house and found that
there was actually a hidden section in
the attic that nobody seemed to know
about and so when he began investigating
this home when he actually went into the
house he found that once he entered this
attic that there was nothing there but
not only that the door behind him had
slammed shut and so as a result he was
effectively trapped inside of this room
for a week or so and so by the time that
Alfred and the police found him he had
been up there for over three weeks or so
and he was recovering in the hospital
from a coma and almost died in the
process and so what Bruce Wayne tells
Dick Grayson here is that the lesson he
learned
over the course of this early
investigation over the course of his
first detective experience is to never
let your emotions guide you on a case
and this is the reason why Bruce Wayne
acknowledges the fact that the court of
owls may exist but he doesn't want to
believe they exist because if he
believes they exist it'll take him right
back to where he was when he was a child
and it'll become even moreso of an
obsession now that it was before because
not only may he have the answer to the
death of his parents but he may also
find or he may also be swept up in this
conspiracy whereby he could stop the
senseless murders of innocent people and
so again what we do here is we pick up
with Batman as he's traversing the
sewers as he's going to the process of
basically going back and looking at the
territory where by Allen Wayne had been
killed and what he tells us is that at
the time that Allen Wayne had died that
the belief was that he had simply just
drowned his body had been discovered
some weeks after he had presumably died
and he had to be identified using his I
dental records but what Batman says is
that after analyzing the bones of Allen
Wayne he found about 50 puncture marks
indicating the alum Wayne was stabbed to
death around 50 times and so again this
really seems to point to the truth of
the fact that Allen Wayne was killed by
the court of owls specifically he was
most likely killed by the Talon but what
happens here is Batman is investigating
this area as he's looking at the various
I guess walls and so on some of the
residues that are left is that he's
attacked from behind by the Talon and
knocked unconscious now from here we
jump to eight days later and I would go
as far as to say where everything that
we've talked about so far is the lead-up
to Batman being captured by the court of
owls this section of the story is the
absolute best part of court of owls and
the reason why is because what we find
here is that Bruce Wayne is apparently
stuck in a labyrinth he's confined to
this sort of underground place whereby
it's a giant maze and as he goes to this
maze this maze has lights that never go
off but more so than that over the
course of this eight days a Bruce Wayne
has been there most likely he's just
been simply losing his mind
and indeed that appears to be the case
and this is the reason why so many
people love the court of owls because
this group effectively came closer to
anybody else to breaking the Batman and
so what happens is
as Bruce Wayne is going through this
labyrinth he begins to have
hallucinations
at first he begins to see the court of
owls which of course they're actually
not there it's an illusion or
hallucination most likely on behalf of
Bruce Wayne we also see the talons
following him in addition we find that
he basically comes across a room that
has a multitude of portraits on the wall
now these portraits seem to span all
over the place there are most likely
hundreds of these portraits then each of
these portraits seems to be one person
that was killed off by the court of owls
now whether they were actually killed in
the maze or they were killed somewhere
else is unknown but all these men are
disheveled they're old they have beards
and so on indicating they were probably
down there for quite some time in
addition we find that as Bruce Wayne
continues to traverse this maze that he
ultimately comes across a room that has
a I guess a mock design or a Makka model
of Gotham City and has a wall covered in
names of the most prominent people from
Gotham City we see Commissioner Gordon
Cobblepot so on these seem to be some of
the most active members of Gotham are
some of the most well-known members of
Gotham and as Bruce Wayne is basically
telling us where as Batman is telling us
that as far as he can tell from this
that he doesn't matter and he's just a
name on a wall and so this is seems to
be the reason why the court of Alice
never actually took his mask off from
him now what he also discovers and this
is very important leading it to the
knight of owls he discovers a roomful of
what appear to be red coffins now one of
these coffins is open and so this
presumably is the coffin belonging to
either the Talon or it's a way for them
to talk Bruce Wayne to saying the coffin
is going to be his but what we find is
that on the cover of all these coffins
are portraits of children indicating
that maybe children had been killed by
the court of owls and they were confined
within these coffins again we're not
really sure here but what we find is
that as we continue with Bruce Wayne as
he traverses this entire this entire
place that he comes across these various
artifacts ships and so on that have
vowels on them and again Bruce Wayne is
really losing his sanity here and
screaming that he's not listening to the
court of owls he's not paying attention
to what it is that they're saying here
and so what happens is that he begins
the I guess begins to approach this room
yet again with the portraits and the
camera that he ultimately begins
to slink away and then cease what appear
to be his parents and so as he makes his
way here this again begins to have a
psychological effect on Bruce Wayne in
the sense that he genuinely believes
they might be there and so what he
begins to do is to talk to them but as
he's talking to them what they do is
they seem to transform they seem to take
on this very disgusting form and then
eventually we see owls actually emerging
from the insides of their bodies and
they begin attacking Bruce Wayne and of
course this is revealed to us reveal to
us to have been an illusion in the first
place but the fact remains that Bruce
Wayne is basically just losing his
sanity here his mind appears to be at
its breaking point and so what happens
is that as he continues to traverse this
that the talus seems to sneak up behind
him and then stab him through the back
and so what we're led to believe here is
that perhaps Bruce Wayne has been killed
by the court of owls finally and that
Batman is no longer a part of the
picture and so what we do is we jump
back to Commissioner Gordon Harvey
Bullock and several officers as they're
shining the bat light into the sky which
seems to explode because of the fact
that it's been running so long and this
is what we start to get into the times
leading up to the night of owls for
those of you guys who were asking
questions about why it was necessary to
learn about the Robins we see the group
is joined by Damian Wayne and Damian
Wayne says they have to relight the bat
land and they have to find some way to
get the bat signal out there if for no
other reason than to help Damian
continue to believe that in some way
that Batman's still alive now from here
we jump back to the labyrinth and we see
the Batman is still alive after having
been stabbed by the Talon but what the
Talon tells Batman here is that while
the court of owls desires to kill him
the court of owls also desires to
basically honor Batman and the way they
intend to do this is to put his bones on
display for the rest of eternity which
is really again as the Talon tells us an
instance where by this has only happened
three times throughout history this is a
great honor for anyone who was killed by
the court of owls now again this is
really more of a sadistic thing kind of
a twisted thing but the fact remains
that when the Talon asked Batman what it
is that he has to say before he dies
Batman makes a joke about the fact that
the Talon had moved the camera now we'll
find out the significance of this here
in a little bit but what we do is we see
that as a Talon pulls the camera from
the ground
again and assaults Batman with it
knocking him to the ground he tells the
court of owls that Batman's now prepared
for presumably to meet his doom and so
his Batman looks up what we find is that
the reason why these lights were in
place was to basically make it
impossible for the person who was
confined within the labyrinth
to actually see any of the members of
the court of owls and so as the Talon
presents Batman to the court what he
does is he asked the court what it is
that should happen to Batman and the
court decided the youngest of them
should be the one to make the decision
as to what happens and so the youngest
child the youngest member of the court
of ala says that Batman should be hurt
she should be he should be hurt more
than he already has been and so the
talent begins assaulting Batman even
more putting him through a wall punching
him so on and so forth subjecting him to
a multitude of punishment and so once
Batman seems to be completely without
any real energy without the ability to
continue on the talent I guess
determines that Batman's been finished
here and so what happens is the various
members of the court seemed to descend
down and begin talking to Batman or at
the very least begin maybe making fun of
Batman or costing him now we don't
actually know if the court of owls or if
any of the members of the owls are
actually with Batman right now this
could very well be a hallucination but
the fact seems to be that the the I
guess the owls the court here seems to
be poking fun at Batman or in some way
maybe killing him themselves and so what
happens is Batman looks over to see the
face of Allan Wayne and the face of
Allan Wayne seems to be pleading for
someone to help him for someone to get
him out of there before it's too late
but Allan Wayne was unable to escape his
fate and so the result is that Batman
takes what little energy he has left and
flies into a fit of rage now at this
point the court runs away they escape
due to the fact that Batman is still
alive and they're trying to escape their
own demise and Batman Begins fighting
with the Talon and so as a two of them
are going out of the fight seems to be
pretty even this is actually one of the
cooler fights and now the new 52 between
Batman and anybody else and so what
Batman is basically saying here is that
as far as he's concerned he's tired of
hearing about owls that even if the
court of owls are real that is
irrelevant that he knows everything
there is to know about Gotham City and
that this entire city this entire model
they've built of Gotham isn't the real
Gotham
court of owls despite how long they've
been within the city of Gotham still
don't know anything about it and so what
he says here I guess the way in which he
indicates this is that he knows that
this is a you knows the location of
whither a des they're actually by the
reservoir there by the river due to the
fact that he was able to taste this in
the water that he had drank he knows
that with the rocket they've chosen with
the I guess the the confines of the
design of the labyrinth that they've
chosen a highly flammable Rock and so
what he had done is he had snatched the
filament out of the camera when he had
initially punched her at the very least
when he was assaulted by the Talon and
so what happens is he sparks the
filament and it detonates the rock and
so what this has done is basically given
Batman a way out of the corridor out of
the labyrinth and so what he tells the
court is that eventually he'll come back
for all of them that he'll come back and
he'll get to get his revenge
and so what we do is we pick up with a
couple of the anonymous members of the
court of owls as they're beginning to
talk about the events has taken place so
far about how this was very exciting
about how it was crazy how some of these
things had unfolded here and so what
they say is that now that they basically
have to wake up all of the talents that
they're presumably going to go about
getting the revenge or the very least
making their move to take over Gotham
entirely that being said we're going to
go ahead and bring this to an end this
concludes the court of owls and what
we'll do next is we'll move on to the
night of owls we'll move on to the
follow-up after this what takes place
when the talents are released upon
Gotham City and this is when we'll
really actually get into the tie-ins
involving some of the characters we'll
see Batman crossing paths with some of
these people as they go through this
entire night of that event all that
being said I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly
Oh